it's finally here The Avengers table has
begun stick to football Sims and left go
together
I think it's Sims and left go finally
stick to football I think that's where
we are yeah or sick to football Sims
aleph go I'm done it it's it's been a
year we've been saying oh yeah we'll do
it
well I'll get the other one make this
happen except for I live in the middle
of nowhere something's really hard to do
yeah now we got you good to be at this
tiny table together well move the hell
out of the middle of nowhere give me a
raise and we'll talk about what better
week to do it though
oh my gosh it is draft week we were
literally right before the start
recording going none of us know what's
going to happen we don't know yeah I
want to say thank you to John Dorsey for
making this fun because when the first
spot is there then everyone reacts
accordingly we don't know know so what
we're gonna do today is we are gonna
take you into every single war room I'm
gonna try and go into the top ten I
think if we move it a good pace we can
go from room to room and here's how it's
gonna go first I want to say Sims and
left go listeners we are joined by
Connor Rogers Matt Miller these are the
stick to football guys their listeners
are called the stickies and we're the
Sims and left keys that are but they
study the draft all year round we've
talked about them a lot and I'm excited
to work with that yeah and first stick
to football listeners we're joined by
Chris Sims and Adam left coach I'm had
the pleasure of working with these guys
for a long time and we have pointed you
to their show so many times if we'll
start to talk in I fell stuff and I'm
good
Sims a left go but here's what we're
gonna talk about kind of our spin on
things so it is good that we can finally
get everything together and get Chris's
perspective as a former pro quarterback
someone who went through this process
because we just pretend to do it he
actually did it and and you're great at
setting us up and also you know keeping
me from saying the f-word wait you mean
it's super exciting because Chris and
Miller usually don't agree and I think
this year is the first year where we're
going to agree I think it's gonna change
no that's gonna be Connors running the
draft for Bleacher yeah by the way you
can watch it on Facebook it is gonna be
able to be streamed in the app and it's
going to be on YouTube this year
Thursday night
you don't need television and
commercials and boring storylines and a
cable bill we're just doing every pic
online so join us no I don't know it's
because he kind of knows who you like he
don't sue Miller less I mean I think
that's a something I'll say to both of
them a course you have Miller's in the
middle of nowhere so I don't get to talk
to him as much but yeah Connor I mean I
lean on Connor all year long I mean so I
mean Sims and Lefko guys if you want to
know what's going on in college football
and prospect during the NFL season you
listen to them because that's the guy I
go oh you know Connor who do you like at
this position or a Connor I just watched
this guy I was impressed or I didn't
like him whatever and we have
conversations and Connor can give me
some perspective of what people are
saying about the guy and if he liked
them and if Miller liked them and at
least just makes me feel like I have
some clue when it comes draft season no
doubt but the best thing about Chris is
that he will take whatever he thinks his
own approach he will know and he'll ask
me for the general consensus but that
doesn't make him scared to say okay well
that's wrong or yes that's complete
nonsense this is what I think and that's
what's gonna make this show so much fun
and that's what we're gonna do here's
the thing I just can't believe we have
to pay homage to you like you're gonna
make the final call I am going to be the
GM in each of these rooms I'll be a job
Dorothy that'll be a gentleman that'll
be a mechag ninh Sims is going to be my
director of player pro player personnel
which means he knows the roster and what
the team needs Miller is going to be my
lead of my director of college scouting
he knows everything and then Connor is
going to be my lead college scout that
knows the in-depth here is how this is
gonna work I'm gonna transport you the
wonderful listeners of both shows to
each war room Sims you're gonna have 30
seconds to give your player then
Miller's gonna give his player and a
brief description why in Connor okay we
are not going to argue off the bat I
want to know who it is
if Simms and Miller both like darn 'old
number one and Connor says Allen number
one he has to explain why he differ
from you right so some of these pics
might go fast yeah some of them it might
become an argument right it's no holds
barred and it seemed to love going sick
the football doing a GM round a
listeners we do this a lot we talk about
its what will happen versus what should
happen right today's a lot more what
should have exactly that's fun yeah
because look no one knows what's going
to happen so let's just tell them what
they should do
yeah so the first place we are going to
go we I'm gonna take you to Cleveland
and the war room with John Dorsey okay I
gotta be honest with you guys I
completely lied I don't know who I'm
taking with the first I thought about
calling a homeless guy I'm not sure
Simms who the hell do we drafted what
help me hey to me the number one guy
John Dorsey okay first of all is Josh
Allen that's the guy I'm going with here
listen uh nobody is perfect in this
traffic the quarterback position bill is
a guy I feel the most comfortable with
especially in the division we playin and
in the weather environment that we
playing as well Josh Allen the physical
gifts yeah his ceiling I think is as
high as anybody in this draft him and
Lamar Jackson at the quarterback
position big arm great size elite size
elite athletics for that size okay yes
you're gonna see you're gonna go Josh
I'm going Josh out is that enough for
you do you need me to supply anything
won't have a picture of him okay good
director of college scouting I would say
John what did you do last year you went
and got the trait sky and Patrick my
home's
right let him sit behind an okay
quarterback for a year and how loaded
that team is in Kansas City the same
damn thing draft Josh Allen lay him sit
behind Tyrod Taylor hey there's no
[ __ ] drafting here let's get the
best quarterback in terms of the future
Sam Donnell might be the best right now
but he might be the worst in five years
I think you got to jump on the table and
take Joshua oh yeah my lead scout my
prized possession I have a feeling I'm
gonna have to do this rant a couple of
times but for me it's Josh Rosen I think
he's the best quarterback in this draft
I think he's the most Pro ready
quarterback in this draft I think he has
the IQ that can handle the demands of
whatever Hugh Jackson needs to not only
survive this year but long-term when I
look at Rosen I look at a player that
can really throw a touch to every single
level of the
field and a guy that yeah Tyrod Taylor
might start Rosen can play and win
football games this year and I feel most
comfortable with him all right so I did
hear Rosen on the Simpson left go
podcast and he was great yeah the guy
that left kogai on the Sims and left
cabacas´s a man he was like below joshua
full-fledged aggressive sorry John
so do you so or why are you against are
you against Josh Allen because I have
two of my jesting I am I'm scared of the
development process with Josh Allen I
truly am I think even though we have
Tyrod yeah I don't know if it's
necessarily a time thing I go back and
watch him against his three games
against power five schools which was
Iowa Oregon Nebraska 50% completion
one touchdown eight picks overwhelmed by
the speed that those defenses played at
that's kind of scary guys how do you
respond I think the three of us could
have would have been his best receivers
Braxton Barrios over here would have
been is number one his offensive line
was terrible yeah and I think that stats
need context how many drop passes were
there how many wrong routes were wrong
how many times was yes play hero ball I
was at the Iowa game scouting when his
receiver dropped a dime that he
scrambled and made a Ben Roethlisberger
incomplete passes yeah I mean it's not
perfect but do we believe we could coach
him up his footwork has improved he was
an over Strider in college we saw at the
senior bowl combine pro day that has
been fixed exact it's gonna continue to
get better
his upside is like Chris said I think
his upside is better than anyone elses
in the dry I don't disagree with the
Josh Rosen thoughts I understand them
like I'm a fan of Josh Rosen you know
that and I do think he could come into
Cleveland and play well certainly but I
don't think his ceiling is at the same
level either and I just look at it
listen in 2018 the biggest thing I would
have a concern with Josh Rosen okay it's
just he is slightly unathletic for 2018
quarterbacks now it's not a deal-breaker
okay
but John Dorsey - is he your kind of guy
Josh Rosen - that's what that's how I
think it plays into this right been hurt
- Allen again - that I just want a
second that thought that Matt Miller
said is that would be a big thing for me
I mean yes when I watched film there was
little mechanical issues didn't see him
at the senior ball I mean he was the MVP
of the Senior Bowl the combine he was
extremely impressive the proud
was I thought one of the most fun
impressive pro days I ever watch I'm
gonna ask this thing to my lead scout if
I end up going with Alan here are you
gonna be able to stand by this to save
my job I will but I will remind you when
we're fired that we could go bad
I do but does Rosen want to play for us
that's that would be my big chapter came
out said he doesn't want to play in
Cleveland [ __ ] that guy if you don't
play for us we don't listen we don't
burn the news in here I'm gonna I'm
gonna make a decision John Dorsey and
and I definitely think that we got to go
hard or go home and I do love Josh Rosen
I really love Josh Rosen but I have two
of my lead guys here I'm gonna have to
go with Josh Allen okay yeah Josh out on
the page and like we all have been
Cleveland Browns select Josh I like all
these guys this is the thing I hate
about this what wait can I just say one
more thing to not even about it but this
is to me like can we get out of draft
mode for a second this I'm just I am so
excited for Cleveland right now I mean I
just don't understand like John Dorsey
okay he was the director of college
scouting for the Green Bay Packers what
is Green Bay never do in free agency
trade
we're signed yeah so you were basically
the GM and you built through the draft
for the Green Bay Packers from 2000 what
a 1 to 2011 what do they do NFC
championship Super Bowl appearances here
he's got America picks in the top 37 and
you got one of the most perfect GM's I
think in football to build this thing
say this I'm a firm believer I don't
think it's gonna be really hard to
replicate the talent on Jacksonville but
in two years yeah it could be a very big
problem with all right so that was
Cleveland now I'd like to take you then
g-man the New York Giants the New York
Giants and Dave gentlemen
hello wait you have to speak I Boston
accent I'd like to welcome you to the
Wellington Mara draft room if you go
over to the corner we have a cucumber
water
look we've been sitting here we have Eli
Manning okay we have Eli Manning
Christopher yes your father was a legend
for us right Josh Allen's off the board
who should we pick a number two I'll say
this quarterback we know it's a need
somewhere down in the future for us for
our franchise I don't have anybody on my
board at this point that I can just say
I'm totally hundred-percent slam-dunk
this guy is going to work and be
successful in the NFL I don't know if
that guy exists this year in the
quarterback class including the guy that
was just picked in number one so I have
questions about all these quarterbacks
Davey Edelman so you're gonna be have to
be the one that's gonna coin it have to
figure out if you feel comfortable at
them okay but I think what I want for
this team when I look at it it's a qualm
Barkley and all the way say Quan Barkley
he's special he's the best player in the
draft we know that yes the running backs
have the longest shelfs lives in the
world no but who the hell cares he's
gonna need a Rickey salary cap wage that
that day is over it doesn't matter
anymore who cares I think he's gonna be
better in the NFL than college because
of what he can do in the pass game and
of course Shermer the way he can build
an offense with running game between the
tackles pass game with the backfield
with the backside of the backfield you
have a special guy where you could have
say qualms Barkley can truly be the most
explosive offensive player in the NFL
next Odell Beckham jr. who is right now
next year to me and if we get a say
qualms we have a chance to be in the
Super Bowl conversation here in the TAT
the end of you like manage career yeah
they should I can't disagree with
anything that Chris just said sacrum
Barkley is not only the best player in
this draft he's one of the best players
I've ever evaluated I will put him up
there with Von Miller Patrick Peterson
Andrew Luck and I don't give a damn
about position of value because like
Chris brought up rookie wage scale means
that it doesn't matter anymore if we
believe the Eli Manning has a little bit
of a window left let's give him the
support we already signed Nate's older
we have great wide receivers not only a
nota Beckham but Evan Engram had a great
year last year certainly
Shepard is an up-and-coming player we've
proven we can find receivers outside of
the first round go get a dynamic
playmaker who let's let's look how
important Todd Gurley was to Jared Goff
or Ezekiel Elliott was to dak Prescott
Leonard fournette Blake bortles and the
guy you drafted last year Christian
McCaffrey in Carolina right Berkeley is
better than all of them because the job
field he's the man this kid is a boy
scout on the field he's Marshall Faulk
yes you want to be the guy who passes
Marshall Faulk right if Christian
McCaffrey can go what number one eight
then this guy can go negative eight okay
that's that's how good hunter
I'm of the understanding that we're not
looking to go for a quarterback right
now but I will take you a little
different route than both of these guys
and say we should take Bradley Chubb
with this pick and here's my reasoning I
think on a grade scale yes Berkeley is a
slightly graded you know better graded
player than Chubb I like the tier two
running backs in this class that we will
have the opportunity to take it 34 or
trade back into the first round to get
those guys are sony michelle darius guys
those players can be plug-and-play high
impact running backs and I can also get
the far and away best pass rusher in
this draft at number two and I would
rather have steak on Berkeley and Sam
Hubbard than Bradley Chubb and Darius
guys mmm yeah I did that's that's gonna
be the decision Gettleman because there
is gonna be some guys that I think are
some decent pass rushers edge guys
they're available in round two - you
know I like the kid from Rutgers yeah
right through terrain
I was always look look when I came to
the NFC East I did some research I
looked at the Cowboys and I saw what
they did was Zeke and I went wow they
could have had a Ramsey and you know
another running back later like a
Derrick Henry so I have thought about
this before now I know that Zeke and say
Quan and and I am having issues with
Odell and say Quan is a very clean face
of the franchise you know a little bit
worried about Odell but what do you
think about what my lead scouts saying
right here about Bradley I don't think
you're wrong by going Bradley Chubb I
don't
I mean Bradley Chubb is going to be the
starting defense end for the New York
jan 4 the next 10 to 12 years would not
we go to a few Pro Bowls and him and
Olivier Vernon fits in the system yes
Chandler Jones you said that I go to the
Super Bowl of sake one can I go to the
Super Bowl with Bradley Chubb yes I just
don't know if he can necessarily make
the difference
in a game on a week-to-week basis like a
say Quan Berkeley Berkeley for me again
chub is special he's not Khalil Macra
Jadeveon Clowney or Myles Garrett
special say coin Barclay is special and
I would say other than Adrian Peterson
I've never seen anybody this special
rather have the best running back in the
NFL or the 12th best passer
that's that's where I think I go into
the fellow's points counter what do you
think I'll stand my ground I look at the
running back position a lot differently
than most people and I have super high
grades on both Sony Michelle and Darius
guys and I feel like I could be
proactive enough to go back and get them
if I fear they're not gonna slide 234 I
would take what I consider a premium
player at a more premium position I love
our corners and I feel like they would
give those guys enough time to get up
you know up hill and get to the
quarterback between Vernon between Chubb
generis locking it down I would go
defense here but I get the argument for
a generational running back yeah I'll
say this yeah you're not wrong you're
not going to be wrong it was great for a
long time when I went down the Panthers
I liked a few things I like power
runners and I like big people on the D
line
Charles Johnson's the guys like that
that mush it up I don't know if I need
to rush end as much Connor I hate to do
this to you it's okay but I'm gonna go
with a generational say Quan Barclay all
right yes but I just can you talk and
get them in Jackson I don't even know
what it it's Boston it's like the
thickest Boston of everybody it's gonna
be fake one goes to the Giants you're
not upset no how could you listen this
guy is going to be a 1300 yard maybe
2,000 all-purpose yard play er you
cannot hate that I'm just looking
long-term picture in a nerdy nerdy
strategy yeah I think for me if I was
gentlemen and I heard all of your
arguments and I heard that chub was
could be a Myles Garrett Von Miller
Jadeveon then I think that the gaps
there totally buts sake one to me the
gap between him and everybody else is so
big that it's hard alright let's keep it
going
this one is going to mean a lot to
Connor so because of that I'm gonna let
Connor go first yes but
me take you into the war room of Mike
mckagan and the New York Jets
we've got Cota backs they're available
big ones small ones fast ones smart ones
it's the New York Jets Mike mechag ninh
here I like it get a little crazy and
I'm gonna go to my Scout Connor Connor
who thought we would be sitting in this
position with Sam darn 'old Josh Rosen
and Baker Mayfield I character I mean
there's a Jets fan this is incredible
this is incredible it's almost too good
where you don't want to decide but I'm
going to decide character I'm going with
Josh Rosen again if I set it for
Cleveland I'm not gonna and I like Sam's
Arnold's I like Baker maybe went into
their war room when you look at Rosen
also the one problem we had with
Cleveland was he didn't want to be there
yeah this guy wants to be in New York
and will thrive in New York this is just
a no-brainer to me i Chris has said this
ayah and Matt has said this I'm a little
scared and hesitant especially after
watching behind Baker the Baker Mayfield
experiment in New York you think I I'm
with you and yeah and arnold's to me has
the highest floor amongst the three
yes but Rosen is an impact guy now I'll
Jeremy Bates pairing him with Jeremy
Bates this is his Jay Cutler that can be
I think will work better right as its
handle so you know Jerry Bates so yeah
it's kind of skipped to you right what
do you think ROC is gonna like them well
I think ROC is going to like him
certainly the other guy I look at like
you know Baker Mayfield Sam Donald they
certainly do fit the system as well I
mean he might want to move the
quarterback a little bit right and
that's where Donald and Baker may feel
they're gonna have a little more of an
advantage over Josh Rosen right with
those kind of things but it's not a
number to pick it's not enough advantage
for me to change my pick and go Josh
Rosen I'm still going Josh Rosen Josh
Rose I think he's the right thing this
team this roster is not as bad as
everybody out in the world thinks it is
we're kind of close Todd Bowles our
coach I mean come on we got a defense
was clicking yes and we don't want to
screw them over with a project type
quarterback so to me Josh Rosen is the
guy that's ready to go right now he can
execute the offense
he certainly will not be enamored with
the bright lights right and I'm sorry
again
Sam Donald there's things I like
certainly Baker Mayfield I can't do
Baker Mayfield in the top five everybody
I'm sorry as much as I like him he's 6 1
and any rate for and it's just hard for
me as much as I like him to pick them at
number 3 so I can't get over that I'm
sorry you're gonna give us our first
consensus I am NOT because I like Josh
Rosen yeah I'm not gonna draft a
quarterback who's been hurt the last
three years and who who's our owner Mike
McKenna who work for right now Trump
what did that hat say that Rosen wore on
the golf course that's a really good
point
Wow no way I'm not giving this kid
that's a really good Sam Donald's the
pet no I like Rosen Connor knows we
talked about it politics and RAF evals
for me Trump had on the golf course when
he works for Woody Johnson
man all right now holla guys let's take
in this new information yeah you're
shaking your head does this change well
that's like if like if we're in the war
room and what he's like the UK well I
hope our owner would just let Football
people make the football decision so let
me ask you this if politics weren't a
part who would you take I would still
take Darnell just because Rosen's been
hurt so much okay I'm getting the
politics are you worried about ginger I
am not because I think we will surround
him with better talent especially
long-term protection don't forget we
don't have to throw him into the fire
right away with Josh McCown I don't know
what you're gonna get what we're gonna
get from Teddy Bridgewater but I feel
comfortable with the insurance that we
spent money on where if our offensive
line is not what we hope to be this year
we don't just throw him out there right
away hmm
I mean and you did draft Christian
Hackenberg Mike so we have that option -
yeah we're gonna forget about that I
would suggest the Mike that you forget
about that one and just move on from it
petty though but
by concerned with rosin I think the
thing you have to get over with yes are
you comfortable with rosin as far as his
athleticism to get out of harm's way at
times that's an issue for me baits
offense you do need some mobility I
definitely do it does and I do think he
is a hair better athlete Josh Rosen then
we've given him credit for but he's
certainly not the athlete Donald or
Baker Mayfield are all right so from
what it sounds like it sounds like if
Rosen didn't have injury issues you'd
like this a little bit more yeah but he
hasn't sing off my head
it might have balls she'd be my uncle
yes balls is the correct all right so
what are you two giggling of that back
there I'm gonna say that while I am
concerned about Woody Johnson
coming down with an iron fist and going
are you kidding me I also think that
someone's actions at that time I don't
think it's gonna continue in the NFL
I've heard a lot of interviews including
one of the sims left go podcast where he
sounds like a good guy
Rosen the injury thing is is tough for
me what were the injuries shoulder and
concussions yes important for
quarterbacks you know your throwing arm
in your brain for documented concussions
I believe too or legit and then two more
very challenges what would you guys be
if I took Sam dart 'old here I'm not
yeah I wouldn't be upset right I'm
comfortable with the floor of the player
fired if you missed anyway so might as
well Sam done right I've missed a lot
this is where I told safer he's safer
this is where but this is where I I
think people are missing out on Sam
darling a little just food for thought
Mike mechag no no case it is a good
situation for him to come into Sam
Donald for me one of the things that I
think people are missing is he's not
ready to go right now he's one of these
podcasts he talked about mechanical
issues that he had he was fixing so I
understand there we have McCown and
Teddy's yes he doesn't have to right
exactly right and I wouldn't depend on
Teddy at all I've known Teddy so the
question is icing on the cake they're
both gonna get time to chill who do I
want to go to when the time is up yeah
who has a bigger ceiling all of
right now Josh Rosen I think Darnell
does I think he's maxed out
I think the CEO I would go down I would
go Donald with the higher ceiling but I
think that also I think Rosen has the
higher floor okay that makes sense
Rosen's the most Pro ready quarterback
in history he's ready but darn 'old I
mean Donald if you told me five years
from now he's Tony Romo ish or Brett
Favre ish I'm not gonna go oh I'm
shocked but also like I told you if he
comes become Shaun Hill five years from
now I'm also gonna go I'm not shocked
yeah that's my problem I'm gonna say
this I didn't know about the four
documented concussions I'm a little bit
worried about woody
I wasn't expecting for you to kind of
flip a little bit too darn old right
there well I just said the high ceiling
it didn't flip I just give me honest
answers Mike I'm gonna go a little
different here and I'm sorry I think
that this scenario could happen that's a
lot of dot connecting that we just did
but it's something that the Jets have to
think about because they are all fired
if they miss on this pick and you can't
in my opinion you can't draft Baker
Mayfield because if he fails you're
gonna get called out for you just Johnny
Manziel yes you can't miss on Josh Rosen
because you're gonna get called out for
the political exactly if it misses only
like the Sims of the where did you have
Darnell ranked in your top five five so
you guys both look like you guys would
be like told you so but I feel like you
guys are in the minority right yeah we
are on the entire board of you the top
five quantum oh oh you have at number
one point four so Connor and Sims would
be like I told you it was gonna be that
good
Miller like I would say that's the
consensus is that dartle Jeff and like
you know the way I do things like I have
grades that go year year he's not graded
out better than golfer wins or Mariota
right he's just he's okay yeah I know I
don't think any of them are on that
level of some of those guys there yeah
we are gonna quickly go back to John
Dorsey and the Browns
at pic number four all right I didn't
have the first Peck figure it out I
definitely don't have the fourth pick
figure it out we went jaw shelling it
one we got a quarterback off the board
sake one a little too taken breaths
maybe Bradley Chubb I'm gonna go to my
Scout again our first overall pick so
you probably disagree with me yes
Bradley chubbs the no brainer here okay
have a pass rush tandem of miles Garrett
and Bradley Chubb we're gonna figure out
everything slowly on the back end but up
front right now we can have a top five
front seven in football when all said
and done at the end of 2018 we got our
quarterback we're good there we got
skilled players around him and an
offensive line BPA and kind of a need
still what's wrong with having to pass
rushers this is a no-brainer at number
four this should be the easiest pick
that we've ever made it should be
Bradley chub he's the best player on the
board I do think that he's I heard
earlier from another war room he's not
on par with Cleo Mac and shaving clinic
I agree I think he's on par with Joey
Bosa though so if we could have our own
Joey Bosa Melvin Ingram but better let's
do it Oh slam dunk slam dunk I mean he's
one of the safest picks in the whole
draft without a no and not a Quinton
Nelson not a Minka Fitzpatrick no good
and we spend money on the offensive line
last year in free agency we're good
there James this is the best guy no
there's corners they need a corner
certainly but not a number four I can do
that corners are deep in this draft we
have like 17 picks in the first two rows
exactly there's get it left tackle to
draft your franchise no replacement for
Joe Thomas no we're not gonna go for a
super reach to McGlinchey no no yes I
think it's jump all the way so we don't
make this pick I quit you have a chub
fortune if that's the case I need to
save money on revenue right Bradley
Chubb is the pick at number four I like
it a lot yeah okay
that feels good now stuff gets
interesting well and that that whole
combination is going to be so cool to
see of Miles Garrett and Chubb alright
let us go number five it is the Denver
Broncos and John Elway
what's up bro it's me J dot yeah
coolest GM and the entire NFL I draft
who I want no one gives me flack about
Paxton Lynch Kazama Super Bowl when in
quarterback hey Sims II who do you like
for us at number five you know I don't
like quarterback at number five let's
just start right there first of all you
haven't been that good at pulling the
trigger and I don't think you'll have
the guts to pull one again okay and
actually be wrong so I don't even think
you're gonna entertain that John okay I
don't think that that's my honest
evaluation of John that's really truly I
don't think he'll have the guts to even
pick a quarterback again early right
here but I [ __ ] you then I like you
regardless but to me if I'm gonna go
with anything here the Denver Broncos
the value for me it's Quentin Nelson
guard here yes this is a team that it
still got question marks on the
offensive line yes I know there's Ronald
Leary in the metalic Watson's Ronald
Leary was not as impressive last year
he's been hurt a number of times to run
with Garrett Bowles last year to say so
young core without a doubt I just feel
like we're a team in general to that's
just not real big and this guy is gonna
give us a little size and physicality
and we haven't had a run game really
since the year we won the Super Bowl and
it really wasn't even that great that
year what do you think yes I think it's
a guy compared to Steve Hutchinson I
think he's a plug-and-play all-pro
caliber left guard you we signed Case
Keenum we don't have a great running
back but we can manufacture yardage with
our scheme and we can't miss again
because you want a Super Bowl but none
of us did so you can't [ __ ] us by
drafting a quarterback that after that
might want to play video games instead
of learning the playbook again
Connor so let's go safe best player
available I agree with these guys and
I'm going quit Nelson yes here's the
point I want hammer home we just gave
Case Keenum a lot of money yeah not long
term yeah guess what Case Keenum had a
top ten run game in Minnesota last year
that's right and if you want your
investment to succeed you better give
him a chance to have a top 10 run game
again there's an easy answer in this
draft to get that it's Quentin Nelson
right this is a almost another
no-brainer I get the argument for
quarterbacks but Case Keenum is in place
there he shown he could win
take the guard that I think is an
all-pro yeah hold on I knew you were
about to do that was just about to say
so we can excuse me excuse me hello yes
this is John two-for-one you're gonna
give us two for one that's a pretty good
deal I'm gonna take it you traded with
Buffalo no that was a Luigi's pizza
that's too far I gots the beat just come
and celebrate quit Nelson governor I
love this kid
I love Quentin Nelson yeah I love you
quit Nelson all I know is when he came
to bleacher report and we was in the
green room with RO Quan Smith and Durman
James he walked out for a second and a
row Kwan and Herrmann looked at me you
were like yo that dude is f an enormous
and I was like and what's funny is is
like you meet offensive linemen like
when I met Donald Penn yeah I was like
you're big but you're not as big as I
thought you were gonna be quittin Nelson
is just it's like a cinder block with
legs it is and and he loves it he breeds
it and like he's a jersey meathead yes
yes he's perfect guard knew you were
gonna get upset if I do the phone listen
let's just have that conversation no
that's good that is this is gonna be one
of the like you know marking points to
the draft right for you guys I mean to
me at this pick and number he'll come up
the Dolphins grab him up but the thing I
hear with the bills is they're only
gonna come up if it's jockey Alan that's
the thing I am here I've been told so
and he's not here so he's not here in
our dress I don't buy the Cardinals talk
but that's one thing I would actually do
John are you still drawing away yes and
I'm afraid I wouldn't want to trade back
but if it were Arizona I think the
Cardinals are gonna be so bad next year
that okay Charton from 5 to 15 sucks but
next year's one from Arizona might be a
top 5 thing that's interesting well and
I mean honestly we just talked about
Nelson if the Broncos trade back to 15 I
mean the kid Hernandez is not I think is
a phenomenal guard he's he's like if any
other draft class he is gonna be one of
the first he's gonna be the first guard
off the board it's just he just got a
super
you know their value out there to our
guy Connor Williams could play garden no
doubt I just I don't I can't quite as
high as that but you're right second
round I think Connor is more value but
maybe I'm wrong I mean I don't know if I
said this at the top of the show if you
are listening on stick to football at
the end of this now that we're five
picks in we are gonna do draft on
giraffe so that will only be four stick
to football it's a staple of their show
so Sims enough go listeners go over
there if you're listening to Sims and
left Co you're gonna get an interview
with Derwin James so stick to football
guys if you want to come and check that
out I know he's been on your show I'm
gonna mess with them I don't know what
I'm gonna do yet but I'm gonna get this
kiss so good he's such a good guess
though you should listen twice
he's Darwin James is going in the top 12
I can just tell you I've heard it I just
have heard it from too many of my
friends throughout the top 12 who were
going there all pondering Derwin James
so to me that just tells you that tamp I
think it's Miami
it could be Miami I mean you could make
a case for Tampa I think you can make a
case of the giant straight out of the
pic they could do that because I just
look at James Boettcher D coordinator
Arizona who was this metal linebacker
Daniel Buchanan during when James can be
that kind of guy just makes sense
there's a few teams there Niners yeah
Niners right they all could do it let's
go to the the middle of the country
basically a novice is an amazing I'm
really intrigued what you guys are gonna
say six duck in the draft it is Chris
Ballard and the Colts here's the deal
guys
I'm trying to win and I don't know if
Andrew Luck is healthy
I have literally holes at every single
position of my team and yet I'm Chris
freakin Ballard and people think I'm
gonna turn this around where do I go
mission impossible realer I'm gonna
start with you here how do we turn this
around for the Colts I think we started
that process last year Chris you're one
of the best evaluators in the NFL you
think you have a great team here in this
front office I think we got to keep
building a strength we took Malik hooker
yeah that's year we took Quincy Wilson
let's go get dinner ward and finish this
thing with a fast feisty guy at the line
of scrimmage
awesome instincts and in the division
that we're in I think we can dominate if
we can win up to secondary we got a lot
of picks in the second round we can get
a pass rusher we can get a running back
we're not gonna find a corner like
Denzel Ward in the second round what do
you think Connor I love where our
college directors head's at but and I'm
gonna stay defense but I don't want a
corner I want real quants myth this is
to me a top seven talent in this draft
we weave holes everywhere get the best
guy this is one of the best linebackers
in college I have ever seen the way he
can take over the game in coverage
against the run sideline to sideline and
as a Blitzer and as a leader this one
listen are people gonna be surprised
yeah but we're gonna laugh at them in
three years when this guy's a top two
linebacker in the NFL and Sims Wow I
like the thoughts of all those guys I
don't think we can be wrong with any of
them really I don't
yeah are you siding with one well I'm
not gonna side with either one of them
actually you know I like Denzel Ward
he's not my favorite corner in the draft
so I think it's a little high to pick
him at six for me okay bro Quan I can
understand okay thank you Chris shut the
[ __ ] up tell me you argue later
I want Marcus Davenport yes and I'm
obviously here in the minority here with
this to me listen this is a team that
needs different makers right now there's
no most people can't even name a person
on the front seven of the Indianapolis
Colts they definitely have needs at them
in the secondary active corner position
linebacker too as well but I just look
at the defensive line of going then we
haven't had a pass rusher since Mathis
and Freeney we don't have anybody that
anybody's ever
been scared of Davenport even though I
don't sit here and go he's a definite
superstar a lot like Bradley chub I go
he's gonna be your ten year starter off
the edge of the defense there's not a
lot of people on planet earth that are
265 pounds in ran four or five and can
play with the physicality he's not
perfect I get that like the bend all
that I wish it was a little bit more but
man I think he's a freak off the edge
and he can be extremely disruptive so
this is the first time that we've had
three separate ones we have to eliminate
one of them Miller if you had to
eliminate one of the other people who
would you eliminate I would eliminate
Davenport I think he's a reach here he
is an upside player I mean yes you look
at his combine numbers they matched
Jadeveon Clowney so he has special
that's pretty I think we need right now
though and I feel like he's a year way
we saw it at the Senior Bowl day one day
two he was overwhelmed by average guys
he did turn it on a little bit day three
but by then he may have memorized the
snap count Sam is who would you would
you say would you eliminate Denzel Ward
or oak Juan Smith who I would I would
probably eliminate Denzel Ward okay yes
and then Connor who would you eliminate
I would eliminate Davenport because I'm
scared of the mist potential here on my
regional write-up I wrote that this guy
reminds me a lot of Carlos Dunlap which
is a nice player not a player I want to
take in the top ten and if your players
eliminated Sims yeah that's okay what do
you think when you think about what
you're hearing about the net I mean I
don't think really the need there it
matches both guys like we have a strong
need there definitely we got no corners
I mean nobody even knows the name of our
corners I know
middle linebacker position listen it's
not a strong group we're not desperate
for me we just good I would favor a rock
Juan Smith I would yes if you just gave
me my opinion out of those guys there I
like Denzel Ward don't get me wrong but
ro Kuan I do think is got some physical
traits that are special his explosion
his acceleration sideline to sideline
yeah this day and age in the league in
the NFL is you all this question because
we keep bringing up later picks Colts
got some picks coming up until a lot of
them a lot of picks they got three picks
I believe in the site we have three
picks in the second round is it more
likely that we could find a line backer
like ro Quan in the second round a
corner like Denzel or a past
sure like Davenport what's most likely
the corner depth is the corner is where
you come find then maybe we could find
dens I guess we have so many holes like
we might was probably gonna fall because
of character and I don't think the gap
between he and dens award is that great
no offense
so then when it comes to a line box I
did no offense be a GM and gross
eyeballs ok linebacker we have to talk
about remaining admins yeah we can't
bring up eliminate down to a position I
just think his name should be so what do
we do you think they'll row Kwan or or
Davenport who are we more likely to find
the second round
I think Davenport's just such a project
okay I'll say this you won't find a pass
rusher really worth much in this draft
outside around one I think all the
really legitimate pastors are gonna be
gone by like 45 take a chance on like
Arden key which is a big mark could be
Alden Smith with no off field my last
point though is that and this is my
personal P reminded me of DeMarcus Ware
I'm just gonna throw yeah that was the
guy I kind of wrote ro Quan Smith to me
is special there are a handful of blue
chippers in this class and he fits the
bill yeah and I want the special player
I I don't he's higher on bro Quan than
me I'll say this I'm just gonna tell you
from you know Chris I'm gonna give you
information to people I've talked to her
on the link please listen there's some
people that think row Kwan's certainly
one of the best players in this draft
the auditor is yes totally question row
Quan Smith in pass coverage that is my
only issue with him I do think he's
drafting both them both these positions
suck in this draft is the problem
because I'm not taking a linebacker
outside saying you 5 million you figure
it out man all right well I mean Irsay
gave you a whole thing of cash and bag
because I have so many picks and because
this is the rebuilding of the team I'm
gonna lean on my scout here
I'm gonna go roll Quan Smith I'm gonna
take a guy in the middle that I know
what he's going to be yeah and I'm gonna
take a lock Marcus to have him board I
think is a good player
but I want to hit and while he could be
Aldon Smith he I don't know if he could
be dion jordan you know I mean I don't
know how it's gonna go here I'm gonna go
roll Quan Smith right all right so the
draft we have right now we have Josh
young gone once a Quan going too darn
old going three four we have Bradley
Chubb by 5 we have quit Nelson 6 we have
Rowland Smith so some of those blue
chippers are kind of coming off yeah
this definitely happened this way
quarterbacks slide in fact and equal
access so Baker Mayfield Darnell are
those the two that are gonna fall if
people the quarterbacks fall it's gonna
be those two you're right for my money
now we will take you down to Tampa Bay
and Jason Lee and the house that Chris
Simms built with the Buccaneers with his
12 career starts
I'm Jason light and I love pirates and I
badges and parrots on my shoulder
welcome to the Bucs Yoho Yoho the
pirate's life for me former quarterback
Chris Simms and now my director of
profile like for the Bucs at seven with
all the guys that are still left on the
board well listen there were a team
again that we certainly have holes on
our roster right I mean oh line yes is
certainly in hole you know defense end
was going to be a hole going into free
agency it's not any longer
so I will say that to you first Jason E
Curry jpp we've got them on the football
team right now so we are not desperate
to me the number one issue with our
football team is secondary that is a
issue for us we have exactly right and
we need a player that I believe that can
just come in here and play and be
professional and really a can't-miss
prospect I want you to take Minka
Fitzpatrick that's the guy for me
Minka Fitzpatrick yes you're gonna watch
the film and go what position is he
against either way he's gonna be one of
the three best free safeties in football
for me right away with other value along
with it and he's the kind of guy for a
team that needs multiple secondary Pires
really during this draft he can do
multiple things according to the week
according to the matchup of the team
he's playing according to the injury
status
guys in our secondary if there was a
week and we said damn our nickel guys
hurt we need Minka to play nickel he's
gonna be able to do it at a high level
our starting corners hurt yeah we don't
want them to be the corner all year long
if you play the Saints but I can play
that position and still be successful so
I go Minka mr. Sudhir where you guys
said Miller where you go I've been said
for months that safety is the biggest
need for Tampa Bay I mean Chris Conte's
has started for Christ's sakes so you
have to do something here
I think derma James is an interesting
name to talk about because of the
athleticism and I haven't if it's
between them to safety yeah who can shut
down the run game we have to do the
album Kimora Mark Ingram right Christian
McCaffrey maybe eventually but I think
it's making Fitzpatrick you're going
Minka I am okay character great is
off-the-charts hi we need that we need a
leader on this defense in the secondary
doesn't eat their fingers right or blow
them up with fireworks both of them your
interesting team to play I think he can
like Chris said according to what your
matchup is that week he can be a Jalen
Ramsey or he can be a Jamaal Adams you
can move him around get whatever matchup
you want and I think the miss factor
with this guy is almost zero and that
was nothing great at drafting you're
right with these guys I think they also
make up Fitzpatrick this is this is one
of those situations where an outstanding
football player that's a need somehow
fell into our lap very similar to what
we saw which Amol Adams with jets last
year now when you go back to something
that our director of pro player said
this is a guy that can play slot corner
this is a guy that can come downhill in
the box he can blitz they didn't ask him
to play single high alot he has the
traits to play single high safety we're
not a defense Jason that really like is
always living with this strong safety in
the box and that's the kind of system we
run so to me Minka fits our system to
Jason we were was awesome I get that are
we worried about maxed out potential I
hear that a lot about Nick Saban guys
and I should I be worried don't think so
because I think that actually think that
tide has turned and I think Nick has
done a much better job of not overusing
his players and with me move around
physical athletes there than five years
ago when it was all about let's just get
big guys and overpower teams no we've
seen the last few years they're getting
the speed guys that
we always were kind of like and they
don't have those guys so I don't worry
about the bus I watched the kids since
high school to Jason I saw him have a
pick six to win the state championship
against your bril peppers and Darwin's
awesome right Derwin scares me for the
scenario you said like you got the backs
coming out of the backfield Irwin's
gonna be awesome as a strong safety in
the run game but man
Derwin would scare me one-on-one with
Kamara or Christian McCaffrey coming out
of a sure you all watch the Florida
State game against Louisville when
Darwin did not want to take a clean
angle and hit Lamar Jackson well no he
was gonna play it safe to make sure he
didn't miss him every time I agree with
Jordan area quickness is his biggest
negative for me
I think mink is the dude Connor you like
me I love Minka and that's it was a
seventh pick in the NFL Draft the Tampa
Bay Bucs select Minka Fitzpatrick now
let's go up to Chicago with the eighth
pick in the draft lion pace and the
Macao skis why are we doing the Macao
skis all on this side it's the Macao
skis on that side it's the Macao skis
it's fighting for ownership of the Bears
it's a franchise has a long history of
being one of the four faces of the full
of the entire NFL but now with Matt
naggy and true Biscay anything is
possible
big offseason guys I'm gonna start off
my Regional Scout Connor Connor where
should we go at 8:00 I'm a little
disappointed with how this board fell I
think I thought we would get you know a
premium premium player to fall into our
lap but I still like Denzel Ward for us
the corner I think we can use corner
help I think this guy can really mirror
and match with any wider seer no matter
the size he is small that's the knock on
him and it's very fair but I got to see
him on the road this year when Ohio
State came to Rutgers and be on the
sidelines and stand near him the arms
are down to the ground the athleticism
is elite I think this guy can actually
be a true number one corner and it's the
thing we need Miller I think a true blue
chip player did fall to Lawson that's
remained Edmonds we need linebacker help
we haven't had a good defense as Brian
Urlacher was here let's go get the next
Brian Urlacher in a 19-year old who's
six foot five 260 pounds from us a four
five flat we could put him on the edge
we can stack him a linebacker he can
cover tight ends
two-seam I loved Enzo Ward I worry about
a 190 pound corner in our division
holding up against some of the bigger
guys he's gonna have to face and just in
the cold weather as well I know he's
from Ohio State but that's a lot on a
little body he's probably a slot corner
I think we can get Isaiah Oliver at 35
when we come back around you get more of
a big fiscal corner
I want your main edmonds I second that
notion I would go Terme Ned moons as
well Denzel wore a corner play certainly
like crossed my mind here yes and Denzel
Ward I like him again he's not my
favorite corner in the draft too so
that's why I don't necessarily like the
value there but Jermaine Edmunds to me
for all the reasons and Matt Miller just
talked about yes he is a perfect fit for
the scheme it's at three-four defense he
could be there Patrick Willis slash
Brian Urlacher for Vic Fangio who came
from the 49ers and ran this similar
scheme now you know the other thing you
got to play and take him to play I mean
free agency I mean Kyle fuller is a
shutdown corner not everybody I think
has really realized that yet but that
name is gonna be a household name and
they resigned Prince Amukamara
I don't think they're desperate at
corner yet and I like Miller said I
think they can maybe get some value
there in the next round right but
Edmunds is a three for middle linebacker
if there's a negative of his game I wish
he was a little bit more of a
sledgehammer but like Miller said he's
19 years old yeah and he hasn't even
really scratched the surface he's still
growing cotton you're the odd man out
here what do you think about what you're
hearing I mean I think the athleticism
is off the charts for Edmonds and I do
think the ceiling there is blue chip
Talent I do have some concerns on film
and he's 19 but sometimes run fits he
does look a little lost sometimes he'll
take the wrong angle to the ball or hit
the wrong gap and that leads to big
plays so is this a guy we feel
comfortable putting on the field next
year that's up to our coaching staff I'm
personally not 100% comfortable with it
it's a projection my question would be
I've heard from other war rooms that
they keep talking about you know there's
it's real quad and Jermaine and those
are the two linebackers and there's a
big drop-off before Lord Evans and stuff
and we keep talking about the amount of
corners in this draft is this for you
this is our one opportunity to get a guy
then maybe get a corner later or as
Denzel that much better in your mind
that you need to get them now I do think
Denzel is a tier above a guy like an
Isaiah
so yes but also I will say the one guy I
would like to target and I don't think
he makes it us in the second round is
Rashad Evans at linebackers so that is
my concern I think we might have to take
the linebacker now and looked around to
at a whatever it's in Isaiah Alvar
Carlton Davis does Mike Hughes slide
Jireh Alexander are people concerned
about the injuries because he's around
one player these are things that we got
to monitor with this situation I think
what I'm gonna go here at number eight
I'm gonna go with the majority it seems
as though I'm looking at my board and
there's not a lot of blue chippers left
and I think when the corners there's
just a lot of depth there and I think
maybe we can go in a little bit later I
don't know if we can get a 19-year old
freak linebacker like this no I just
know people miss them out you'd be ready
right now but if I'm taking a guy at
number eight yeah I don't need him I
don't necessarily care that much about
right now I just wanted to be amazing
for his career yeah I'm gonna roll the
dice a little bit the value I think to
that maybe gets missed a little Jermaine
when you evaluate the college film to is
Virginia Tech does a lot of stuff on
defense they slant the D line this way
and the linebackers come that way so it
can look weird on film and be a hard
eval like Conor made some of the points
with the run Fitz and things like that
like yeah there is some of that but I do
think some of that is created by their
defensive scheme too but the other thing
I think there were he's gonna succeed
more in the NFL than College the length
and the acceleration and athleticism to
me in the pass game he my experience is
a quarterback playing against the ER
lockers and the Keith Bullock's of the
world when they're in the middle of the
field and you go damn there's six three
or four and their arms look like they're
a bald eagle okay and then they can run
like they're a legit force strong safety
I go with the bear but it's scary it's
scary as that is a thing where their
ability to always throwing their and let
me just accelerate to the ball and
create a collision or to throw around
them I always like we we play against
Anthony bar twice here so I kinda and
that's my comparison for him now
that's funny yeah all right now let us
go this one is a special place and our
director of college scouting director of
player personnel let us now go
uh to a place that is many say the
future of the NFL right let's say you
let's see if the pile shadow yak sorry
John Lynch Jimmy Garoppolo this is the
San Francisco Miller who would you like
to crown with the ninth pick to join the
future Super Bowl champ well let's just
see if Kyle's gonna listen to this
podcast okay let's just see if he
listens okay yeah cuz every now and then
I'll listen Kyle I am calling you after
your first round pick tomorrow live on
bleacher report last year we did it last
year I actually don't think he still
knows nobody told him and I was not
going to tell you anything he says but
they might be on the phone well we kind
of screwed ourselves here boys because
Ross Smith and Charmaine Edmonds are off
the board and our middle linebacker is
probably going to prison so we're in a
little trouble I look at what's
available I think Denzel Ward is a great
player but not a fit for what we do
schematically I actually like our
safeties enough to get by Tchaikovsky
tart really came into his own last year
I'm gonna roll the dice here there we go
Marcus to have important we need a Leo
we need someone who can get penetration
can it can bend the edge Salomon Thomas
are the number three pick in the draft
last year didn't have a great rookie
season and I know he was a young guy
that needs she needs to learn but I
think what Mark has to have a port we
can get six to seven sacks this year in
sub package and we can bring him along
and make him like I heard someone say
earlier he's an Alden Smith type player
with no crazy off field exactly to go to
my fan base and for like the fourth year
in a row four out of five linebacker
right outside linebacker okay I'm not
gonna make this any easier on you Obama
to go Harold Landry because this is a
player that I watched in 2016 and over
summer and I know Matt agrees with me
yeah said this is the best
pass rusher in the class eighteen and a
half sacks and seven forced fumbles in
2006 absolutely dominant now you talk to
people around him this year he played
hurt and he looked hurt he was not as
good against the run and was not as
productive getting after the quarterback
I think healthy we get back into him
being a double digit sack player and a
guy that fits exactly what we need after
all he left but Leo that's exactly right
he fits all right so we have Davenport
and we had a with Landry I just want to
put that out there I'm okay with that
too
I'm okay with both two I'm okay with
both I mean I didn't expect I didn't
expect Davenport to be on the board here
either
and maybe my evaluation was wrong but
this is definitely a positional position
of need I mean for our footballs to the
fan base John by saying we spent money
on offense we got you Jimmy Garoppolo we
brought in I said Jerick McKinnon we've
we brought in Western Rick Berg we spit
on Johnny Lynch okay Johnny Lynch this
is what I do to see like Davenport I
think is maybe the more for sure thing
right now Harold Landry to me does have
incredible up size an incredible talent
last year is a little enigma and the
injury thing from what I hear is
certainly somewhat real but also does
that these injuries affect him going
forward we have to really we have to
sometimes we take that into account we
go well they got hurt last year go back
to the year before well maybe he'll
never be the same again that's what I
always worry about a little but I don't
worry that totally here with this
situation Landry has special bent I mean
special
it's like Von Miller ish I mean his
first step off the edge his ability to
go them round the edges is amazing a
shoulder dip is phenomenal Davenport is
gonna be your slam dunk mister pedal to
the metal gonna play hard gonna be
awesome against the run but there's a
few more questions about the ability to
bend around the edge sorry you decided
between those two I think I am with
these two on the board right here now
listen I'm gonna throw another name into
your mixture because I do think that
much of a mic McGlinchey and we do have
a head coach in Kyle Shanahan who is
obsessed with athletic Limon who
run the football and I look at
McGlinchey and go he'll be your right
tackle next year okay cuz Trent Brown is
a gigantic man and I just don't think he
fits into our own system it's a weird
scheme fit and I look at look at my
Gucci I can't move
he'll be a right tackle for two years
and then he goes to left tackle and
there's your franchise left tackle I
think he is it can be today is getting
old gettin up there see you guys both
like the pass rusher edge what do you
think of that last suggestion I Connor
actually I think it makes a ton of sense
when you look at it now there's been
talk that this guy would go in front of
us potentially to the bears or he'll go
right after us to the Raiders so if we
want them take them now because there's
no chance we get we didn't even know
he'd be here because of the Bears but
now we got lucky enough where I can
definitely work with that right so I
want to do this I want you to tough
decision after these three guys in yeah
is Harold Landry
McGlinchey and Davenport John is there
one guy that you think we can eliminate
right now can we trade that would be
their suggestion quarterback called my
other suggestion Landry is the best
talent out of the three to me he's Vic
Beasley ish I'm willing to eliminate
Davenport because what you guys are
telling me is I look at my D line and I
have a lot of people that don't let bad
things happen but I don't really have
somebody that makes bad things I have
the exact same grade on those two and
Davenport to me from what you guys tell
me sounds like a guy that's a lot more
solid but Landry could take us to
another level so I'm gonna eliminate
Davenport for Landry but now I'm
thinking about McGlinchey cuz that whole
future plan sounds interesting right
with Jimmy Garoppolo G for me is one of
the safest guys in the draft and a
pounder and I think Landry's day1 ready
I don't think he's an up side guy I
think he got hurt last year the year
before that he was the top ranked player
that's a guy he's a [ __ ] baller he
can come into play yeah but with
McGlinchey how bad are all these
offensive tackles coming out of college
so we have a chance to get a
plug-and-play guy who's not great mm-hmm
but is he Taylor the one probably I
could be that good I agree I mean really
yes it was really good
yes he can be that kind of run blocking
tackle for your team that's the thing
so I want your final vote Sims
McGlinchey no McGlinchey Dan that's a
tough I'll still stay with Landry
because I don't think we have any chance
of getting a player like him at all
I'm I just think he's a difference maker
up front getting after a quarterback and
that's the most of the other thing you
don't think internationally 39 because
that's my final mock draft I just
invested seventy plus million into
Garoppolo and Staley is leaving
eventually Trent Brown is a good guy
that maybe I could get something for him
if I'm John Elway and I want to trade
John Lynch set so I met John Lynch and
then also I do think it's gonna be hard
to draft another defensive pass rusher
or someone on the line yeah for the
fourth time in 58 five years I think I'm
gonna go McGlinchey here okay cuz I it's
a little bit of safe that's providing
safety for my most important position
and it makes my head coach very very
happy yeah I'm gonna go McGlinchey yeah
I think that has to be taken into
account the fact that we re talking
about Landry out loud
I think Landry could be one of those
guys that might go to the Colts at six I
could see him maybe going to the Bears
like I could see him being a surprise in
this trap I would agree I mean what if
chub goes at four is there any chance
that Landry could go at five no no I
think so you don't think him Shane ray
and Von Miller chub was there at five
yeah yeah
McGlinchey is an x-factor of this draft
I mean I think he could be the guy I've
heard everything across the board
starting out I wanted to throw that in
because he and the Bears new offensive
line coach are best friends of course
right and you don't want to overplay the
whole connections but they are tight and
I can tell you at the USC game earlier
this year when I was covering Notre Dame
on NBC the Bears scouting staff was
there to look at the Notre Dame
offensive linemen I'm just doing some
more I know that the link has always
been there with Quintin Nelson to the
Bears the question is that bears with
McGlinchey yeah I think thank you as
much I have to change his pants if he
got McGlinchey or Nelson it would be my
only thing I mean now
we're talking about the Bears again the
only thing I'll say with the Bears is
their old line is really good that's
it's not a desperation thing like where
I look at them and go ooh they need that
so badly it's a pretty good group and
they've drafted some high view high
round lime in the last year's and I
think the thing is to with with the
Niners it's like an investment property
yeah you know like those tackles one of
them's opening up soon the other ones
gonna open up in a year the Niners
conversation is fascinating to me too
because just the fact of like also
didn't bring Joe and James into this
well I think with the corner thing to
like the scheme fit I think that's the
thing to like when I've run the Seattle
scheme you don't need you don't need a
man-to-man shutdown corner in the top
ten because why you don't play
man-to-man that much so that would be a
waste to me they've been a long time
right let us go to the final pick in our
little situation here pick number 10 all
men
I love the Steve segment I know you're
expecting Reggie McKenzie member is
jungrin Steve now and you're selling
John Reggie out to lunch told him there
was a two-for-one sound down at Subway
Jon Gruden Simms you look familiar
I'm not good at imitations yeah and the
only thing I know about Jon Gruden is
the word man so then it all turns a town
I gotta figure out who the hell weave
Drew's been drafted not in order but I'm
on my board say Kwan's go on Bradley
chubbs gone Quinta Nelson's gone
Tremayne Edmonds is gone Sam Darnell's
gone Meghan Fitzpatrick is gone Josh
Allen wrote Quan Smith and Mike
McGlinchey so that's available on my
board first would be Denzel war to be
best available Darren James Connor
Williams Markus Davenport Harold Landry
so those are his best fellow this is
amazing and our little mock here
Mayfield and rose and our falling out I
don't this is crazy
I think with no trades this is a Miller
of your top available who are you going
with for the reasons where it didn't
sell works you come off the board just
put put him and Gary Connolly
yeah if Gary and Kylie can get over the
shin splints those things are apparently
really really hard to get over yeah how
are you doing because you're overweight
not a shape that's what you had Miller
also an awful town but so you'll
probably take someone like I don't
Orlando Brown here okay I got a boring
pic here but it's in necessity be Nevaeh
the middle because he's a guy that
really is gonna control double-teams yes
he could push the pocket but he's gonna
be the guy like snacks Harrison was for
a while where you're saying oh [ __ ] like
nobody runs the football on their
Oakland Raiders anymore
this is a need that has been a problem
for a long time and there's an easy
solution sitting there on the board now
I thought a lot you know I can consider
someone like Derwin James here just
because he's that good at this spot but
I'm still gonna take the need and I
think Darwin is a hard fit with Carl
Joseph yes they meant a lot it said what
about open
right well I'm not giving up on that yet
so you can screw both you guys okay you
guys haven't seen him really play okay I
gotta throw some questions out to you
like listen these guys they've thrown
out vitae via certainly good we do have
some big people in the middle of our
defense and we have spent pics on that
again yes we obviously have to improve
our run defense and all those things all
together certainly but I also would pose
this question for you with the safety
question as much as I loved Erwin James
yeah you know Reggie John whoever you
are right now yeah you got to figure out
that we got Reggie Nelson we got Marcus
Gilchrist we got you know the kid from
West Virginia and Obi bel and fondant
play so there's a lot of players at that
position linebacker was certainly a need
for us but there's nobody there another
linebacker right so now where do we go I
think to me and my personal view would
be a vital via certainly in that
conversation I would go the next guy
okay is I'm going Jair Alexander over
Denzel Ward I like Junior Alexander more
corner battle you have a corner battle
yes a giant Alexander excites me I think
he is a true man demand shut down cover
corner he's gonna fit in the Paul
Gunther scheme as far as what corners do
for them I would think Anakin returning
kicks first and he can be truly one of
the best punt returners in football
worried about the knee I hear you he
didn't play hard late on to the I went
to Scouts X Games frame and he wasn't
even on the field there's only six game
I play five it sounds like we're
definitely going defense yeah they're
going defense there's no value I mean
are then let's do this offensive line
it's sneaky I would consider right
everyone will probably laugh this I
consider Isaiah win here because he
could play tackle and guard and it could
be very good at both really good I don't
think he can play tackle that's what I
would get concerned with it he can't or
he could play guard a more decent guards
so that's what scares me yeah all right
so let's do this so it's not a magic
gyre Alexander you like Denzel Ward and
you're picking Vita Vega yep so the
corners are the same yeah if you could
choose my really Michael Hughes but the
the field issues and we just got Darryl
Worley he's gonna really scare me and I
mean damn we're the Raiders and all but
we can't have a bunch of probably Jon
Gruden is gonna like draft Calvin Ridley
if this happens and none of our opinions
I mean I wouldn't be shocked if he took
DJ more right here I mean who knows such
an analyst
all right so orderly Shia Alexander and
Denzel Ward who do you like of those two
I like Ward because I do have a slight
fear of the medicals with gyre okay
that's the big that's the big note for
me okay
so I'm gonna have to kind of knock out J
you're here because I think that the
safety of Denzel Ward here and this pick
I like so then that between now it's
between Denzel Ward and Vita Vega
so Miller I was your time I like him
and we've talked a lot about him on six
football I have a hard time taking a
nose tackle at 10:00 overall with the
way the NFL is going and he's a really
good nose tackle he he can place some on
third downs but he's not gonna be you
know an interior penetrator this isn't
Gerald McCoy who we're talking about
it's maybe like mid-career Haloti Ngata
where he can he's great at stacking up
blockers and he could shed will but he's
not gonna he's not gonna have four or
five saxes season I know you're a little
concerned about his body well his body
is is it does concern me like four or
five years from now yeah I mean if he
has a lazy offseason and he decides to
eat a lot he'll be 370 that's over but
but man it's hard to argue with the
results there Johnny boy oh yeah I've
never seen anything I've never seen a
body that ugly that's that athletic
totally agree disruptive and I do think
that this is where me and Miller
disagree invited Beata I think there's a
little more value in the pass game than
I think he's gonna be able to push the
pocket and shoot gaps a little certainly
was way better than I was expecting I
was expecting to see Danny Sheldon just
plug her and then all sudden I was like
damn this guy's all over the freakin
field so I would call him a disrupter
he's Denzel Ward going to be a disrupter
Danny's on board I you know I'll lead
off with my concerns okay Denzel word is
a phenomenal man-to-man corner there's
really on film not much not to like I
just don't think there's gonna be a
whole lot of play making I worry a
I'm like being a Ronald Darby not making
a whole lot of plays on the ball I came
at a Florida State his body is not the
greatest and I thought this is my number
one issue with Denzel word in transition
if he was playing the slot and the guy
made it and he's backpedaling and now
has to brake on an out route from the
slot I did not think that was on par
with the jl 'ig Sanders and the mic use
of the world and it's the reason he
didn't run the three cone or the 510
five at the combine because he knows
it's not that great at least in my
opinion I'm just gonna but I think the
Amana game showed some of those concerns
saying he struggle with breaking balls
and comebacks against Semmy Cobb exactly
struggled a little bit worries me
I like Ward just because I feel like I
mean he was a one-year starter so he has
some ceiling because he was behind
Marshall Adam or Gala apples I don't
think we've seen his best ball yet and
with gyro Alexander I do I mean I worry
about the knee and what it was with Vita
baya
I think that the thing that it's a very
good point is that yeah I mean if he has
a boy he's like whatever I'm just gonna
eat rice yeah and what are you thinking
here mr. V Nevaeh
I have to stay out of the ninth pick in
the second round - yeah we can get drawn
pain in the second round
yeah but on the flip side to me we might
be able to get it you know in Isaiah
Oliver I don't know if he falls that far
I like MJ Stewart Mike Hughes how far is
he gonna focus again I think he's the
second best corner in the class yeah
probably likely first early so right I'm
standing my ground because I think v2v
he's been you know labeled as a two down
player and I don't agree with that I
think he's a three down player and a
very very good one last point for each
of you what are your last final votes
I mean Jon Gruden skin um my my final
vote is I think if I had to go here I
would go vitae via mail I think it makes
sense I like him and he will immediately
improve the run game I think the middle
linebacker for the Raiders is trashed so
he might as well try to stop the run
this way oh I will I'll take it
you're gonna take photovia yeah I'll go
with it I think dudes are wards better
but it's cool just it ends award just a
mess with them
yeah günther to like I mean they need
both positions an option here I don't
know just ask yeah we're gonna go it's
the thought I mean there's none deck for
the Oakland Raiders so that means
try and do this off the top of my head
the number one picked the Cleveland
Browns go Josh Allen the number two pick
the New York Giants go sake while
Bartlett number three pick the Jets go
Sam darn 'old because of Joshua Rosen's
F trump hat I love that for Cleveland
Browns easiest pick in the draft is
Bradley Chubb Broncos come and go
Quintin Nelson at five six Indianapolis
Colts we go with Roe Quan Smith
middle of the defense guy number seven
is going to be the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
and they go with Minka Fitzpatrick eight
is the Bears we have them taking
Jermaine annemun shrimp was it number
nine the Niners go Mike McGlinchey and
number ten the Oakland Raiders go v to
Vega and that is the Simpson left go
stick to football right round table
let's just real quick talk about who are
the guys that maybe could sneak into
this conversation right yeah those we
and we have Rosen and Mayfield falling
and then at 11 the Dolphins take
Mayfield I think they would take Rosen I
think - yeah I think they would take
Rosen I think they would take Baker I
don't know that he wants the best in
there so let's say our thing happens I
think then at nine there's gonna be a
lot of teams trying to get ahead of
Miami
yeah there were that's what I think the
trades I think the Niners could take
advantage of it yeah
the Raiders are in a nice spot the Bears
are in a nice spot once it gets out of
like five or six Cardinals could be
trading up Ravens could be trading up
Chargers could be trading up it could be
really interesting can be I mean it is
because we're all so well the Harold
Landry discussion this is a phenomenal
discussion I mean yeah he's a special
guy at a very valued position football
right we didn't have Derwin James
drafted right no we don't everyone's is
the same time I think it's a special guy
for a position that is in premium in the
NFL right now so those are guys we
missed on I certainly the sizes like
this are really good because fans will
say no no Dermott James is a top-10 pick
yes okay but doesn't know where to go
out right I know that's what he is he's
one of the ten best players or 15 best
players doesn't always mean you
necessarily get picked in that region
final thoughts I think it's time for
some
I've done girafft all right perfect yeah
if you have been listening on sims and
left go you are about to hear our
interview with Derwin James if you are
listening on stick to football you're
about to hear draft on draft which is of
course Sims left go fans suddenly do at
the end of every podcast so Sims and
left go go listen to the end of stick to
football finish the episode and make it
a completed episode then leave them a
five-star review and if your stick ball
come back over to Sims and left go do
the same thing and listen to the end and
get that five-star review
we love you all join us Thursday night
we're gonna be on Facebook live YouTube
and also the be our app join us it's
gonna be sick
Connors gonna be announcing every pic
we're not waiting on TV we're gonna try
and give out the pics as early as we can
and we're not messing around talk to you
soon
well look who it is can't buy the
t-shirt that fits them the extra smedium
he's got on to show his muscles today I
got a chance to hang out with Derwin for
Old Spice we did a little smell test he
couldn't decide between peanut butter
and cinnamon but what you don't have a
first round nose I know that you
wouldn't you didn't know where there is
peanut butter or coffee that's amazing
also I hear you got stuck in an elevator
well yeah Dallas the Dallas knows you're
gonna be off the board by the time
they're picking they're trying to get
you you know trap they don't want to
worry you anymore let's get rid of all
right we have we have Derwin today
thanks to old Spice's new flake defense
two and one anti dandruff shampoo and
conditioner Wow
I think you could use that giving guys
great hair with long lasting scent and
dandruff fighting power all in one
product learn more at Old Spice comm
derma man I'll tell you what he talks to
a lot of dudes in the NFL and a lot of
guys right now are going I don't know if
Derwin is gonna last long yeah I will
I'll second that I mean Derwin first of
all you're one of my man crushes in this
draft just because of the style the way
you play it's awesome man
but but
but I do think this is the first thing I
want to talk to a lot of people in the
NFL I mean there's no way you're not
going in the top 12 I hope you know that
and what the one thing I talk to with my
friends around the NFL they're just you
the guy is who they're so impressed to
it they all say the same thing you're
gonna go into the locker room and be a
leader and be one of the main dudes in
that locker room I want to know from you
just what how did you become that guy
what in your background has made you
such a great leader in that guy in the
locker room I want to get him to credit
on my parents my dad my stepdad they did
a great job raising me you know how to
be a role model and you know just how
did not follow people I feel like that
helped me become a leader just not
following people and I'm surrounding
myself either by the right crowd and I
feel like I'm you know I'm a tone setter
some people to like to follow
are you well are you more of a what do
you think you are more of a vocal leader
or a lead by example kind of guy how
would you how would you put it instead
of boy I lead by example because you
know you never have to worry about not
fulfilling on the feel you know the work
speaks for itself so I say both really
all right so you know who you are and
the funny thing about the draft prospect
process is we're always comparing you to
people I've seen everything from Kam
Chancellor to Shawntel all these
safeties I'm curious which one is the
most accurate which one did you kind of
have in the back of your head game like
that is that Shawn play with and then
very nice fast you play the ball and
then also you know like that Palomar
looks like being able to get in a boss
and blitz also yeah so is everybody yeah
I mean you should because you got a
special talent set dude so that there's
no denying that that's where I want to
go to I mean how do you envision being
used in the NFL what do you think out of
the teams that are interested in you
that's a scheme that really does fit
your skill set and what you can do on
the field
[Music]
so I feel like I played well I was like
I'm going to cover three I played well
coming down or playing in the middle of
the field if I go on the quarter to
cover to plan B I'd be there so it just
depends on the team and the system and
what they see me as I'm seeing you've
seen me as playing slot corner that's
not there in the box so government tools
and covering the tight ends though it
just depends on the team I know you love
it all of it like you're you're a
football player I know you do so do you
do you have one spot though out of like
all those that you mentioned that you go
oh that's my favorite I like being the
nickel linebacker or the nickel slot or
the safety whatever it may be I want to
play to see the court has really good I
want to be yeah okay I think I want to
go next do you mind if I steal your
question with that one
you're such a jerk but go now go ahead
really he had a really good question but
I want to take all right you have faced
deshaun Watson and Lamar Jackson and I'm
curious what that experience is like
comparing those two I mean deshaun
Watson I mean he's a great passer great
player been one of the best of it again
and he can also run above the mark
Jackson is just like I mean once he once
he makes his mind up that he's gonna run
the ball he is you got I mean it's been
a planet-sized I'm covering the
receivers downfield I'm I'm just looking
I say oh man he's running again he's the
only guy that made you break down like
he's the only guy I've watched you
didn't just shoot your gun and go knock
his head off you're like oh hold on a
second I asked us to chub yesterday and
I said so then what's it like to hear
the media and all these teams like an
offensive coordinator came out today and
said Lamar is not gonna make it in this
league what do you think when you hear
that having played them I mean I played
against a lot of great quarterback I'm
I'm gonna top quarterbacks in the
country wrong but he's if not the best
one of the best that I've played again
he's not just a runner he can pass and
he's a great leader he gets the team
bond he like the wind man he's gonna be
yeah I mean he's so but you're saying
just to summed up he's in the
conversation for you with deshaun Watson
as far as being that kind of a special
court yeah good yeah we're just trying
to shut some of that crap up up out
there about you know yeah I mean right
alright so at this point here we are
we're just a little over 24 hours out on
the NFL Draft you're excited you're
getting paid by Old Spice you're wearing
your extra medium t-shirt
what well you you with your benchpress
and your guns but but the big thing is
do you have a gut feeling of where you
are going to end up you don't have to
tell us ooh but do you think you know
who's gonna pick you at this point yet
we just did a mock draft and we had a
bunch of people in here and we selected
you going to Tampa at the seventh pick
that's what we're thinking I know you'll
be happy no matter where you go I mean I
know that right right a lot of sacrifice
a lot of people does it make it any
extra special and I've do you care if
you stay in state I mean you know I
didn't get a chance to play in state
where you know I grew up and everything
like that but I mean would it be cool to
stay in Florida in your opinion you how
to go out of state I don't want yeah and
if the Giants trade down and take you
you have to let us take you around New
York we're going to show you a good time
Derwin of course is brought to us again
old spaces old spices new flake defense
to one anti-dandruff shampoo
or go to Old Spice calm Durham meant
congratulations bro
enjoy we're rooting for you man kick
some ass man we'll see you we'll see you
come in here at next year you got to
come here and hang out with the animals
I'll slide your DMS so you end in that
and you went and that's why everyone
wants to draft Erwin James yes why
because just like how because that
wasn't like Josh Rosen so like now I'm
on the Josh Rosen scale and obviously
durman's my boy right but I'm just
curious yeah he's not like maybe quite
the you know gonna say these deep
intricate answers like Josh Rosen but
just the you could see how comfortable
he was I mean he was so willing to
basically run the interview 71 as soon
as we came on before we started
recording it was just very easy there's
no you're not gonna give me any credit
for them certainly the relationship
happened but it just shows me again
though this is what teams are talking
about I gotcha easy you could just tell
he's a leader he's had a great support
system as he mentioned with his family
you know life and that shows and
everything he does I didn't realize that
I completely messed up when I told him
where we had him going in the mock yes I
did I actually we haven't even had you
go yet
I mean you're like you're deadly gonna
top 12 and then in my head I was like oh
man we didn't dress you know I'm going
yet but uh no I yeah I thought he went
seven if he did not yes no it's all
right but he could very easily go
seventh I think that's a very real
conversation that's going on in Tampa
right now every single guy that we asked
about Lamar it's not a bowl or you could
play you can do it right
Pires know when it comes to like guys
they've seen in person and played
against and been on the field or played
with and been on the field and practiced
that's when they really know now if it's
guys they haven't seen or whatever it's
like players aren't the guys are gonna
study but men I mean you know in the
world of the the freakiest of freaky
athletes yeah even than an NFL team
after a few weeks of practice everybody
goes yeah I mean we're freaks but that
guy still in another level
apparently he's compared to three guys a
lot kam chancellor Eric Berry and Sean
Taylor right which one is he actually
close I just see
Eric Barry as much as the other two I
think he's more Sean Taylor than
anything Wow right that's a hell of a
converse I know the only negative I have
with Durham and James in general just
there's one negative to his game is just
I worry about like short area quickness
if he had to cover a back out of the
backfield man-to-man I don't necessarily
think that's his strongest thing but
it's not a deal-breaker of course but
again his top-end speed his
aggressiveness his willingness to what
we would say in the NFL to shoot his gun
to go oh wait there I recognize
recognize this hole I see the running
backs the only diversity screen all
right going I'm going and I'm gonna
knock his head off that's what I love
about is he also think about this this
is the kind of guy that played with
Jalen Ramsey and all of those teams and
all of those guys are having a ton of
success right now yes and I know that
our guy Michael Felder loved Erwin James
how can you not he's he's a man he's our
kind of guy I mean he's no-nonsense I
just think I would I would implore
anybody go online and look up Derwin
James in a bull rush against the Florida
offensive linemen yeah
when turan James a safety lifts and
offensive lineman off the ground with
one arm and then tosses him to the
ground yeah it's just a special athlete
yeah and he's my buddy I know he is he
likes you and I do think it's not a
character flaw is that a red flag but no
I think um I think sometimes were I miss
on Derwin James guys is not necessarily
the fact of German German James but
maybe I think I don't quite give the
significance of that position in the NFL
right now it's it's just do right how
it's sold you're sitting next to mr.
safety yeah I know
mr. multiple positions all over the
phone like the Eagles when Ronald Darby
got hurt yeah relied on the three or
four safety cents at some points this
year and think about the value of a guy
like Malcolm Jenkins to that TIA
and their ability to guard the receiver
in the slot and go back and and think
about Devin McCourty to the Patriots the
really smart defensive teams one guys
that can play all over right and he
could be a linebacker yes he could be a
safety he could be a corner ya know he's
going to be an in the Box safety I think
for the most part
you're gonna see him used like a
whatever I you know what I got a he's
almost gonna be more like damn Buchanan
Kelvin Smith I think than anything at
the end of days gonna be like that kind
of guy mark barren right I think so
alright guys I hope you enjoyed what we
did was stick to football if you are
stick to football fans and you're
listening to us now we had a pleasure
having yeah I hope you guys really
enjoyed it we love those guys Connor and
Matt or awesome I'll just kind of clear
it out one more time Thursday Night Live
you could either watch it on Facebook
you can watch it on YouTube or you can
watch it on the BR app we're also gonna
be making videos for the BR app so I'd
highly recommend that it's a really good
time but it's gonna be me Sims and
Miller on Thursday night me Sims and
Miller on Friday and then Connor and
Miller taking you home on Saturday it
should be awesome it's gonna be a lot of
fun yeah well I am too this is going to
be a draft where no one knows anything
No so you're gonna see genuine surprise
to reactions on this desk and we're
following Twitter we're not waiting for
television because that is old news for
Sims peace out homies I see fender ik
good evening Avilan and the lef koe mom
says good night thank you don't list it
again holler at you Thursday night it's
trap bye bye see you soon
[Music]